in this video today we are going to
discuss about the four forms of godzilla
singular point
while the other godzilla movies normally
have one form of godzilla and maybe over
the years he evolves and grows into
something better
but all except for shin godzilla they
were all constant in design in the same
movie
godzilla singular point is yet another
anime of the g-man
but here the monsters are quite
different and the backstory 2 is unique
godzilla 2 has a unique storyline and he
has 4 different forms
which evolves as the series goes on the
series is already out in japan
and will be released worldwide on
netflix on the 24th of june
now let's get down with the sickness
origins
this godzilla also known as gojira as
always
in the nigashio legend was prophesied to
cause the end of the world
when the waters became crimson now the
creature was initially discovered by a
submarine team who had been stopped by
it
half a mile beneath the surface when a
school of mandar appeared in the waters
off the coast of
the boso peninsula godzilla followed
them into the tokyo bay
evading a navy blockade in the process
it came ashore in tokyo evolving into
amphibia
and then continuing through the city and
furthering the other evolution processes
that result in an ultimate form
so form number one godzilla acquires
well this is the first form that was
seen in gods of a singular point and we
all thought it was daytonosaurus at
first
godzilla aquarius has a crocodilian-like
physiology and also like a mosasaurus
and some of those characteristics it
features red violet scales
and orange tail fins as well as orange
stripes on its back and pale yellow
ridge plating on its underside
it has huge dorsal spikes that go all
the way to the tail
and the spines are jagged with vein like
features that bend and come
as they travel the creature also has
four large
web flipper-like legs 900 meters beneath
the sea godzilla cordless was detected
moving swiftly on the radar of a nearby
submarine
an operator on boat confirmed that the
creature was screeching at the sub
and soon began approaching it rapidly
and as you can imagine they were all
shocked at what was this monster that
was coming at the submarine
it was actually chasing a group of
mandar that were running
away from it and they came and they made
landfall in tokyo
and then it engaged in a brief struggle
with one of the manners and after
killing it
it took on a second transitional form
better suited for terrestrial
environments
form number two godzilla amphibia the
second form came
immediately after aquarius and it
evolved right after killing and
consuming some of the manners that were
fleeing away from it into
dry land godzilla amphibia looks a lot
like varan
and a hybrid with godzilla himself when
it evolved it still possessed three bobs
instead of a splayed fin
and his hind legs are smaller than his
four legs in this form and they have
evolved from the fins of a cordless
his head is similar to varens and he
retains a row of godzilla-like dorsal
fins
from his aquarius form although they are
framed with varanesque
spikes on the talon his back is covered
in a knobby scale
carapace and the scales also run along
the limbs
with only his underbelly being smoothly
textured
godzilla amphibia engaged in a brief
battle against the military
as soon as the tank stopped firing
godzilla released a flammable vapor
freezing the area of which
it breathed when a tang shell hit
godzilla's face the blast was absorbed
into a vapor causing it to explode
and create a giant mushroom cloud
reaching a height of 500 meters into the
sky
godzilla was burned but created a shell
of his second form
and began evolving inside it form number
three godzilla terrestrus this third
form of this strange godzilla shows a
more terrestrial form that looks more
like a dinosaur
including a hunched poster of the t-rex
and a long tail of a carnotaur
a ghost of terrestris resembles his
ultima form
but is thin and has a gorosaurus-like
trait
his skin is green with a yellow
underbelly and he has an extended face
with a huge lower jaw
and eye situated quite near to the snout
of his head
godzilla thrusters roars are combined
from the heisei era and millennium
series
and when he was struck with the missiles
he released kind of like a varan
gorosaurus slash baragon roar before
turning slowly into a normal godzilla
roar again
and form number four godzilla ultima the
final form has yet to be released in the
series but it will be shortly
and will appear as the one seen in the
trailer with a deep charcoal hue and
white dorsal plates with red
vein-like patterns flowing through them
godzilla singular point
has a more monstrous look kind of like
the a combination of a
heisei period godzilla and shin godzilla
there are also a lot of jagged teeth in
the design
and its neck and forearms the creature
contains several osteoderm-like
structures similar to those found on
crocodilians
this incarnation has a narrow tongue and
many rows of teeth
and three tubes in the rear of its
throat rather than
standing straight up it takes more of
like a dinosaurian posture like a
terraport like position
kind of bend forward but also retains
its godzilla
unique characteristics godzilla is
referred to in this merchandise as
godzilla ultima derived from the latin
word ultimus meaning the last
it is unknown at this time what
significance this title has
though it could be speculated as it
means that this godzilla is the last of
its kind or maybe
the last and fourth form it takes on a
style of shin godzilla which evolves
four times over the span of the movie
kinda like the same one but this time
it's an anime
now let's look at the powers and
abilities of this evolving godzilla
like all the incarnations of godzilla
godzilla ultimate can fire an atomic
breath as well as
godzilla terrestrials will kind of
nevertheless while swimming godzilla
cordless is able to withstand
significant underwater pressure
this was shown when it stopped a
submarine that was diving depths of
around 900 meters below
godzilla cordless is able to swim at
speeds of around 50 knots
while in its second form it was able to
travel on land
godzilla amphibia has exhibited
incredible resilience to a type 16
maneuver combat vehicle's munition
which is kind of like a tank even when
hit in the face and other sections of
his body it did not really do anything
godzilla thrusters has a similar ability
as another monster in the series
and gears with the exception that it
only reduces damage from powerful
weaponry
causing him to bleed a little when the
missiles hit him but then
it can regenerate at a fast rate
godzilla can evolve into more powerful
forms by feeding on other kaijus
godzilla koala's first stage was in the
water but it transformed into godzilla
amphibia after killing one manda
after fighting the jsdf godzilla
amphibia cocoon himself inside a
shell where he began to transform like a
butterfly
and in the next evolution it is godzilla
terrestris that is much stronger and has
some new
snook ring abilities and can work
properly on lan
the creature's final stage godzilla
ultima is yet to be seen but it will be
much larger than his previous forms
and will be darker in coloration as well
as have more upright stature
godzilla expels massive amounts of
energy from his skin
in the form of a red dust in all four of
his forms generating a dense cloud
around him
within 500 kilometers godzilla amphibia
may emit an explosive mist that swiftly
cools the climate
godzilla terrestris is able to extend
his blood and turn it into a
tentacle-like formation to attack his
foes
and he can extend his arms to make them
become twice their normal size
if injured godzilla terrestris will
display a healing factor which
allows him to heal his wounds in a very
fast rate
and well with that we come to the end of
the video on the four forms of gods at a
singular point
which is also known as gura goji so hit
that like button for support and
subscribe to be a part of the minecube
family
and one more thing smash that bell
button for regular updates on monster
videos
right here on minecube till the next one
take care fam